well joining me now is the chair of Brit
PC UK and former politician Henry Bolton
a broadcaster Jenny cleeman well welcome
to both of you
um Henry Bolton when swella bravaman
uses a phrase like invasion
she does it to Rally the rights uh to
Rally people who think we are literally
being invaded by illegal immigrants
that's not true we're not being invaded
by illegal immigrants they're not
invading us these are in many cases
desperate people coming because they
have nowhere else to be they've been
maybe in war-torn countries not all
summer gaming the system we know that
but to describe them as an invasion is
such inflammatory stupid rhetoric it
appears I'm going to partly agree with
you and partly disagree
um we talk about Pitch invasions are we
saying that that's inflammatory the
answer is no and of course comparing
refugees and Asylum Seekers to football
Hooligans I I think actually I think
actually appears you're comparing the
language that you'd use regarding an
invasion of a football pitch with
compared with what the Home Secretary
has said literally just compared
refugees and Asylum Seekers to football
Hooligans
Henry that again is what I call
needlessly inflammatory yes you've asked
me a question and you've answered it
because you're now making an accusation
about something that's not true what are
they saying what I'm saying is that you
that there is a hypocrisy amongst people
in the media who are saying Suella
bravaman is wrong to call this an
invasion when actually one of the
accepted definitions of invasion for
example you can have an invasion of
flying ants you can even sorry did you
have a look in the dictionary sorry so
you're now comparing refugees and Asylum
Seekers bottom line here is football
Hooligans and flying assets people do
not understand
that the majority of people as you said
in your introduction are highly
concerned about this yes and the
situation is that what we've got in the
media is people focusing on whether the
Home Secretary called it an invasion or
whether or not the instead of whether
the government's got a plan to solve it
and what I agree with you on is that the
government doesn't have a plan it hasn't
had plan for years and in this this
situations
that's what we should all be focusing
literally it's the government developed
but the reason we're focusing on the use
of language is precisely for what you've
just done you've just compared Asylum
Seekers and refugees to football
and that is incredibly interesting
here's 42 of the people who've come
across the channel since May this year
are albanians 95 of which are young men
between age ages 18 and 30 70 of
albanians in the UK do not come from
Albania did you know that I do because I
was a un governor in Kosovo I was
advised to the our brain Urban prime
minister and I led the UK's efforts in
the Republic of Macedonia next door to
disrupt transnational they're also
perfectly entitled Henry they're
perfectly entitled to try and come into
this country yes they are then they
should be processed and they should be
processed because there is an asylum no
if they qualify for them and they are at
the moment but they are not for example
in Germany or France because Germany and
France have said no because Germany and
France recognize that Albania is a safe
country and the reality is that we've
got an issue here which comes together
and I'm not I've got Albanian friends
I've worked in it don't try that
don't come out with me you're really
being quite aggressive you're trying to
imagine because of the language the
language is no my language they're all a
bunch of people Hooligans invading is
there a bunch of flying ants my nods my
real people you did you compared them to
flying ants peers would you please let
me get a word in yes thank you I said
that I feel that's a hypocrisy between
the media who are you perfectly happy
using the word invasion in relation to
football fans and
and you are saying that bravaman's not
right you'll call it a football Invasion
but I'm sorry let me explain
ridiculous teachers a thousand people
all right
I think here's the problem the Casual
use of this kind of language and analogy
part of the problem is that when you
compare genuine refugees which many of
them will be people seeking Asylum many
coming from countries which by the way
have been warts on because we started a
war there not in Albania would you oh my
God no but we have it like Iraq right
now right 12 000 people
I mean that's what you should be holding
the government we're going to explore
that but generally the use of
inflammatory language this is part of
the problem if you demonize all these
people that to me doesn't help anybody
the point is you are deliberately either
setting people up as your enemy that
invades you or you're dehumanizing them
ants or or cockroaches or or whatever it
is
all she's got is rhetoric can you name a
single thing that she's done in all the
time that she has been in the cabinet
she has nothing she has no ideas she has
no plans she just has language where she
talks about her dream of sending people
to Rwanda she talks about tofu eating wo
karate that's all she's got culture wars
she uses this language to deflect from
the fact that she doesn't have a plan
and the problem is not the invasion of
migrants the problem is the backlog and
the backlog is caused by problems at the
home office with processing people yes
there is a record Henry you would agree
with I would agree and yes 14
governments to solve problems of nearly
this scale I agree and my point I would
totally agree there is no plan process
is wrong the law is wrong that there are
these knee-jerk reactions coming out of
the home office and the government such
as you were quite quite right I totally
agree with you regarding the ridiculous
idea of sending them to Rwanda this is
all ridiculous stuff the fact is that
there is no cohesive strategy and that
without that strategy there is not going
to be a proper plan cross-government at
the very least but the very least the
very least we should be doing is
treating these people with a basic
dignity and respect I agree they're
prepared to risk their lives which many
of them do and many have lost their
lives in the process of coming over the
channel in dinghies because vile
traffickers have screwed them for
however much money it may be the least
we can do as a supposedly civilized
Humane country is has actually treat
them with some form of dignity can we
not forget that there was a terrorist
attack on an asylum Center on Sunday and
we know that this kind of language
dehumanizing language treating these
people as Invaders people who are coming
to take over our country people who are
insects is the sort of thing that
enables terrorists to commit these
terrible attracts Henry let me ask you
something Andrew Henry Baldwin you were
very exercised about the just stop oil
activists and you tweeted this arrest
charge for criminal damage prosecute
sentenced to whatever community service
hours are required to clean it and find
whatever it costs jail for six months
very strong unequivocal this is how we
deal with them right I'm a former police
officer as well and I have arrested
people for lesser criminal damage than
that yeah they've been they've the crown
prosecution service have made the
decision to charge they've gone to court
and they've been sent to jail and given
community service and what was your
reaction so what was your reaction
through a petrol bomb and a Dover
migrants I'm appalled okay yes
it has 140 reminds you of what you
actually tweeted go ahead and then
somebody threw petrol bombs at the Dover
Migrant Center which is on fire then
took their own life the shocking news
shows the level of frustration it does
it's shocking news because
you're not you think it's not shocking
and you think that this was an absolute
racist lunatic fine waging a terror
campaign
migrants migrants there is something
that I think all three of us can you see
more you see more appalled and more
Draconian about a bunch of people
spraying paint on buildings now you've
been you are about a bloke trying to
murder people now you're being
ridiculous
that's literally your tweets within the
space of two days that is the contact
context of what we I think all three can
agree on is that the government doesn't
have a properly cohesive and thought
through plan for this yes
you're going to see these problems he's
not justifying them fine it feels like a
joke it does it doesn't unfortunately
you put it down to it shows how
frustrated people are no
murderous Maniacs who are racists who
want to kill migrants of course that's
what that's code Piers if you look at my
career I've spent most of it fighting
people like that you can understand
people being confused you can understand
that you see more angry about just you
may be confused I am not you didn't say
we're in most people you didn't save
adjust up all protesters were frustrated
that's what led to them doing what they
did you said lock them up I agree
unfortunately you can't lock that man up
can you right what I am saying what I'm
trying to illustrate here is that there
is a need to put pressure on the
government to come up with a cohesive
plan and you cannot deny all right Jenny
if there is severe frustration look I
think most sensible people can agree it
is ridiculous these numbers rocketing of
people coming over illegally on dinghies
and it has to be dealt with and nothing
so far as word but I think we can also
agree that this country needs a good
level of legal immigration of people who
will enhance our country and right now
if you speak to anybody in many
Industries like Hospitality for example
and so on NHS they are crying out for
people absolutely my sister runs a
restaurant she is trying to uh recruit
from overseas because she cannot she
cannot recruit absolutely it's a
complete catastrophe and if this is what
taking back control is I don't know what
being out of control is it is a complete
disaster this is a problem of our own
making we could have done a lot better
to control our borders if for example we
hadn't been deliberately alienating but
the French by saying we didn't know
whether or not they were our friends or
are or our enemies there is so much more
that we could have done this is uh
entirely a failure of 12 Years of
conservative government we've had think
about it we've had the ridiculous the
Hostile environments policy we had the
Rwanda policy we had the whole window
it's all been a disaster and what we
need is proper leadership to actually
sort the two problems out one how do we
stop people risking their lives and
possibly dying being trafficked over the
channel and secondly how do we have a
better system of Asylum and refugees
which actually deals with these
applications quickly and we work out who
should be here and who should because we
actually lag quite far behind many
European countries on how many we take
in any way good and competent Home
Secretary to do that though one that is
driven by practice appears I think
that's what the conversation that really
we should be having and all of us
putting pressure on the government to
respond I agree
n started in saying that the use of
language is very important you do not
get anywhere in this debate by
demonizing people by using sub-human
language about them and for my point I
would like to say that I agree with you
I I do not and have not equated however
you'd like to put it however you'd like
to present it I have not equated the
refugees and the Asylum Seekers and
migrants okay let me explain President
Putin okay or let me explain let me
explain exactly they are simply let me
explain large numbers
exactly let me explain exactly how you
did compare them one more time because
you said the use of the word Invasion
about refugees and Asylum Seekers was
justified because we use it about
football Hooligans and flying out I said
it was exactly I'm afraid and if you
listening also posted the Oxford
dictionary definition of what invasion
is and in that sense it's difficult
no it's not difficult it's only
difficult if actually you look at them
as less than human
Jenny uh Henry Bolton thank you very
much indeed still to come